the story of the man who gave his name
to sideburns sideburns as we now call
them go back a long way a mosaic from
Pompeii depicts Alexander the grape with
a pair they were a sign of authority
with the Hindu military class known as
cash atria and the Meiji Warriors of
19th century Japan in Victorian England
they were called side-whiskers and were
worn by important gentlemen like Prince
Albert and Charles Darwin men with
lavish facial hair
Winona's whisker and o's the style had
several nicknames including Piccadilly
weepers named after Piccadilly in London
where men's sporting this kind of facial
hair would hang out
and done drear is often lured dumb
dreary an exaggerated liebe whiskered
character in our American cousin popular
play of 1858 it was this play that
another man with distinctive whiskers
was watching when he was assassinated
Abraham Lincoln but the term we now use
sideburn dates back to a rather
unfortunate soldier of the American
Civil War general Ambrose Burnside while
still a young man he was left standing
at the altar by his fiancee who ran out
of the church crying no siree
I will not later as a commander in the
Union Army
Burnside's military career was less than
brilliant he was considered ineffective
at the Battle of Antietam and held
responsible for the union's crushing
defeat at Fredericksburg and when he
discovered that his former fiancee had
become a Confederate spy Burnside had
her seized and kept under house arrest
for months despite these setbacks before
his death in 1881 Burnside had become a
household name not for his military
service or misfortunes in love but for
his luxuriant of facial hair
it was so striking that the name
Burnside whiskers was used to refer to
the combination of a moustache and side
whiskers in the British Army side
whiskers were always joined together by
a mustache because until 1916 soldiers
were banned from shaving their top lips
eventually the syllables were reversed
to give us sideburn
very bushy sideburns that cover the
cheeks are known as mutton chops because
they look like a cut of meat sideburns
were worn by a rebellious Teddy boys in
the 1950s and favored by movie stars and
heavy rockers in the 60s and 70s they
were less popular during the
clean-shaven 80s but have roared back
into fashion with today's hipsters the
sides of March campaign recently
encouraged men to grow sideburns to
raise funds and awareness about male
suicide in 2015 a new catwalk trend
emerged for women's sideburns the next
phase in the never-ending pursuit of the
her suit thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and click the bail
to receive notifications for new videos
see you again soon